[Music]
Thailand's Highway 3259
is a sugar cane transport Road
thousands of farmers use it to get their
crops to the refinery
[Music]
but this highway has a toll collector
locals call him the dog
and this is his territory
[Music]
he's a master deal maker
calculating risk versus reward
to get what he's do
[Music]
the dawn can actually sniff out when a
delivery truck is on the way
he can gauge quantity
using his sense of smell alone
targeting the trucks carrying the
biggest loads
[Music]
time to collect his toll
[Applause]
thank you
170 pounds of raw sugar cane provides
the 70 000 calories he needs every day
but the dawn
is not on his own
he's brought some younger Bulls along
henchmen
to show them how it's done
[Music]
together
they watched The Dons technique
he knows that if they aren't too greedy
the drivers will pay his toll
and in return he and his accomplices
will stay out of their sugar cane fields
their observation and knowledge of us
has helped elephants to get by in an
Ever more human-dominated landscape
[Music]
but their long-term future may depend on
us understanding them
as individuals
[Music]
thank you